at this organic farm in Sardinia good
practices keep animals healthy and
reduce their consumption of antibiotics
making their meat safer to eat
drug-resistant spreads from animals to
humans through the food chain to halt
its transmission the European Parliament
is working on new measures curbing the
preventive and collective use of
antibiotics yo no no delete the
antibiotic that cousin quiescent rava
don't seem to me get all veterinary or
cause an offence of Ceuta leads are low
- from determine after couple the
preventative use of antimicrobials will
be limited to single cases where the
risk of a severe infection is high and
certified by a veterinarian
Davalos other antibiotic exclusive our
male team presents animal 1850 vets
opportunity region and Botanica some
antimicrobials will be reserved for
human use only mep s also want to
encourage the research into new
antimicrobials and to impose the
reciprocity of EU standards in the use
of antibiotics for imported foodstuffs
support on the Henryville maximum la
présence don t boutique don't live
yonder kiss also operated on in european
miss well if younger and 50 mostly
cooler you passing the reciprocity
it is so CN under the new law only
trading partners who comply with the
same limitations as their EU
counterparts will be able to keep
exporting their meat products to Europe
you